In New York for a very exciting shoot.
And I wonder whether you guys can pick up on what it is
based on the hints in this video.
But for some reason,
I'm unable to sleep in.
I wake up at 7 every morning regardless.
So I woke up
and decided to just use that time to read my book
that I still have not finished.
And I've been reading it for three months.
I wrote lucky a little note to find while I'm gone.
Started getting ready for the day.
Bucky swears by icing his face every morning
and every night,
so he's been getting me into that.
And it is so cold that it's almost painful.
But my skin always looks and feels amazing after.
So I might have to do this a little bit more often.
I've been craving the tuna cotto sandwich from Joe
and the juice for so long now,
so that's the first thing I had to get.
I got the spicy tuna cotto with extra avocado.
Lucky just went to get that for me.
And after I had breakfast,
I realized that I was running a little late.
So I got dressed really quick and headed over to set.
I had a later call time today,
which was really nice,
cause usually it's around 6 a m.
And today was 12:30.
So I love that.
But my hair and makeup done
and the note that I left,
lucky asked whether he can surprise me.
With dinner.
And he found that note
and said that he's gonna set something up.
So I was very curious what that was gonna be like.
Wrapped about six hours later,
and I headed back to the hotel.
At this point,
I was absolutely exhausted,
but so excited to go on a little date night.
So I did a really quick makeup look,
got dressed,
and we headed out to dinner.
I'm very glad lucky checked in.
What I was craving today,
because this hit the spot.
But nothing describes the feeling of getting into bed
after a long day.